i am telling you from the bottom of my
heart everyone the next biggest thing
since the internet itself and social
media itself is now upon us it is called
the consumer blockchain
when i really analyze
what has allowed me
the great flattery of having a speaking
career and having successful businesses
and being a happy person
professionally
i do a lot of things well i do a lot of
things not well
we're all that way
but at the end of the day there's always
been one thing that i've done
exceptionally well
and i define it in my mind as day
trading attention
the one thing that i know
whether you're
an entrepreneur whether you're an
executive whether you work for a fortune
100 or whether you work for a fortune
1000 or 10 000 or 100 000
the only common denominator that i can
talk up to
in a room of this size and bring value
to each and every one of you
is predicated on attention
the currency that we are all battling
for
to achieve anything we want including
knowing that many of you
have your professional wants and needs
but there are things that you care about
in your life
outside of your work
whether it's
a family business that you're not
involved in whether that's a non-profit
whether that's social issues whether
that's raising a couple of dollars for
your kids school
the one thing that is the common thread
to this room is before you can tell
someone
what you want or what you'd like them to
do you need their attention
and attention has been a huge passion of
mine my whole life
i've been in the advertising industry
for the last 13 years
and vaynermedia has disrupted that
industry quite a bit and it was because
of my focus of attention
many people here
work in big businesses whether it be to
be in b2c
it has been my hypothesis for the last
15 years
that the way they've tried to build
their brands and create sales
has made assumptions
on consumption from television
commercials from digital
assumptions on reports
assumptions on reach
they
buy and spend so much money
to get reach to get awareness
but they accept reports and how the
industry has traded on it
yet it's not true it's not actual
consumption it's potential reach
this thesis that i see from the world's
biggest companies also plays out for the
individual influencers
and creators and entrepreneurs in this
room
that
right now i'll give you a great example
in romania
so many of you continue to be obsessed
with growing on instagram
while tiktok is underused in the country
but the attention is there at enough
scale that the content you provide
would outsize the return of followers
and awareness that you're looking for
we are incredibly good as human beings
at respecting yesterday's attention
and we're terrible at respecting today's
attention because we convince ourselves
that it's tomorrow's attention
this is a framework that i've been
trading under pretty much my whole life
and definitely the last 25 years of my
career
before i get into the state of the union
of web 2
the state of the union of web 2.5 which
is really the big opportunity
while we go to web 3
i want to create context about web one
there are many people in this room
that would never admit
to this
but only 25 years ago
they disregarded the internet itself and
thought the internet was a fact
there are many people in this room many
people in this room
who disregarded every technology over
the last 25 years they didn't want to
put their credit card into a computer
because they were scared their credit
card number would be stolen to buy
something
they did not want to give up their
there's how many people in this audience
raise your hands are over the age of 45
raise your hand don't be scared i'm over
45 too higher
higher
the amount of people who just raised
their hands that did not want to give up
a pager
to get a smartphone
or
my favorite one for everybody who raised
their hands
kids
do you know how many people just raised
their hands that swore they would never
give up their blackberry for an iphone
because they didn't want to give up the
buttons
[Music]
watch this raise your hand if you're one
of those people
how many of those people now have an
iphone
that
what just happened there is what i do
for a living what do you say you're not
gonna do that i know you're going to do
and how do i build infrastructure there
so that when you show up i have more
market share
this happens within
genres
so many people in this audience thought
that facebook and twitter was stupid the
first time they heard it
when facebook first hit the scene it was
only for kids
today
only 15 years later it's only for
grandparents
[Laughter]
[Applause]
this is an important way to start the
conversation with all of you because of
where i'm about to go
we
as human beings
love know
and are scared of yes
it's what we do
we get comfortable
and we are unable to see the opportunity
that is in front of us because of that
fear of trying something else because of
that lack of interest to put in the
extra work to do the homework to
understand the new thing almost
everybody in this room that struggles
with nfts
is only because they haven't done the 25
hours of homework to understand that
it's the blockchain and that's different
than the internet and you're bringing
your internet brain to the blockchain
which is why you're confused
the reality of the world we live in
today is technology is happening faster
and the opportunities happen faster and
the vulnerabilities happen faster and
more extreme
you in a corporation can hold on
you can hold on as an executive
how many people here work at a company
raise your hands raise hide please
most
you can hold on
you know why
it's not your business
at the end of the day i have empathy for
that you're a human being you can't care
about somebody else's business more than
you care about your life
but for the people that have a business
that they own it is their life
their business is their fourth child
their third child their child it is
their family it is their livelihood this
is why
entrepreneurs often will move faster not
because they're smarter really not
because they're smarter
but because they have no choice
they have no choice
when you miss market inside your company
you can resign and go work at a
different company
even a competitor of the company you
just work for happens all the time
that used to make a lot more sense in
the 50s 60s 70s and 80s because
everything moved slower
but what i'm passionate about is flying
into this great country
and looking across this many people and
just getting one
one one of you
to recognize that you're putting your
head in the sand to recognize that
you're living and know to recognize
that you have a lot more of your career
left one of the biggest arguments i hear
from so many people when i talk about
this stuff is like gary i've been doing
this for 25 years i don't have you know
i'm just not going to do this much
longer i don't even have the energy for
this anymore and i always ask them like
how much longer are you going to do this
and often they say
15 years 12 years 20 years that's a long
time
that's a long time
and so i come here
because
2021 2022 and now going into 2023 has
absolutely started the process of us
living in a web 3 world this does not
mean
like some of my friends believe that
we're going to live in the metaverse
next year i don't see it
i don't see people wearing headsets and
spending seven hours a day in the
metaverse i think that conversation is
premature but on the horizon
what i do know though is that every hour
on the hour more people become
comfortable with the concept
of owning
a custodial wallet
have purchased a cryptocurrency have
tasted it have bought an nft
the problem with web3 is there's too
much greed in it because there's too
much money being thrown around
web one and web two was all happening
behind the scenes
web three everybody's trading and people
are getting fomo when people are making
lots of money and people are making fun
of people when it crashes like it has
the last month
all of that is just noise that means
nothing in the macro
the technology doesn't give a [ __ ] of
the price of bitcoin and ethereum
the technology doesn't care if v-friends
or board ape or world of women is doing
well or not well the technology is
the biggest mistake that we make from
america to romania to china and
everywhere in between
is we actually think technology cares
about our opinion
the amount
right
i'm gonna go to the guy who clapped
because i'm very happy with him right
like [ __ ]
as if
the blockchain caters what we think
about cryptocurrency like our opinion of
cryptocurrency is going to dictate the
world's technology
more importantly it already happened
we're not talk i'm not standing up here
talking about web 4
it already happened
it already happened
i watched this movie play out for the
last 20 years with the internet again
nobody would like to admit what they
thought about the internet about email
about the iphone about facebook and
twitter and snapchat and tick tock
nobody here wants to make fun of
themselves for what they actually
thought yet so many of you in this room
are repeating the same mistake again now
when i say repeating the same mistake
i don't think anybody
should dictate
somebody else's ambition
i
think that's ludicrous we all have
different levels of success and what we
want to happen
to me i'm just talking about what's
actually happening how one in this room
wants to decide
what they do about it is on them
some people in this room are actually
retiring as a matter of fact who here in
this room is retiring in the next five
years and i don't mean
that you're gonna build a huge company
and retire and buy an island i mean
you're old and you're almost done
raise your hands put on the lights i
want to see it
i was really hoping you were going to
raise your hands too
hold on raise your hands i want to see
who's retiring in the next five years
one two
all right let's clap it up for the four
old people
so four people out of seven thousand
don't need to pay attention to the next
45 minutes
everybody else here better wake the [ __ ]
up
and let me tell you what i mean by wake
the [ __ ] up it comes in two ways
for some of you wake the [ __ ] up means
actually going on the offense
and making a career change
putting in work to educate yourself for
30 40 hours on all these new things
uh try something on the side
creatively while you do your thing and
pay your bills in case maybe it clicks
and then you can maybe do that
for some of you wake the [ __ ] up means
defense meaning you need to be very
careful
if you are a cliche 38 to 54 year old
executive right now
and you are not paying attention to the
current state of web 2 web 2 5 web 3
emergence
you are going to lose
in the next 10 to 15 years your
opportunity to grow within the
organization
what is going to happen because it's
been happening for the last 25 years
is one of your fellow workers almost
always who's reporting to you or
reporting to somebody who's reporting to
you will outmaneuver you in their
efforts to understand what the consumer
is doing today and for the next 10 years
and when economic stress happens
[Music]
the organization will go with the more
contemporary marketer or decision maker
to get the next step at
this is happening right now i say this
in this room because the last three
weeks of my life have been talking to
fortune 5000 board members and ceos
because the recession is coming and they
know that their marketers are not on it
and they are asking me who in the
organization that i'm servicing that's
not the cmo should get the next job and
none of the number twos are on my
recommendation list
why because of what i'm saying now what
i've been confused about for my whole
career is why people get away from the
trenches
why they become so
about meetings
and boardrooms and lose touch with what
actual human beings do why they begin
to believe reports that are fake
over their own
common sense intuition and what they
believe as a human being
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
this is foreign for the entrepreneurs in
the room because you have no choice you
have to pay attention to what the
customer's doing that's how you eat
it is incredibly real i'm watching some
of the faces in front of me for the
people that are in the trenches in
corporate environments i know why they
do it it's the currency of their
organization it's how bonuses get done
it's how everyone is scored these
reports are broken
we must go into the next decade
becoming more consumer-centric and more
common sense
oriented what i see
that is very clear to me because i lived
through 1996 to 1999 and i lived through
2005 to 2009
is the next transition to how human
beings are going to interact i'm going
to start with web 2.
before i get into blockchain i want to
talk about social media because it will
affect everybody in this room tomorrow
right now we live in a world where
social media is the infrastructure to
communication
of course mainstream media has a place
of course print has a place but let
there be no confusion
the scaled opinion shaping of our
society is overwhelmingly happening
across seven to twelve platforms where
other human beings and organizations are
producing content
there are incredible opportunities for
organizations and individuals in this
room in this world however
most people here today look at these
channels as distribution channels
and so they make a single piece of
content and they want to put it
everywhere
whichever ones they're in
these platforms are very specific rooms
the keynote i will give here
for example me pushing everyone here to
finally open up a tick tock account if
you're in romania is specific to romania
in australia everyone's already done it
it won't come out of my mouth
i know the mix of executives versus
entrepreneurs in this room thus
tailoring my message for this hour based
on the room
if you do not produce content
advertising
information creative that is contextual
to the distribution and most importantly
contextual and relevant to the person
that's actually consuming it you have no
shot of succeeding
we must
all collectively here
take one humongous key point out today
which is
i believe today not tomorrow not the
next day today
the variable of your business growth
from a consumer standpoint including b
to b how many people here are in b to b
raise your hands
including b to b i am i am flabbergasted
by how many people continue to not use
linkedin
to produce three four
five pieces of creative content
marketing a day
a day
i watch unlimited
startup sas companies to fortune 500
companies selling 20 million 50 million
dollar rfp scopes win it on linkedin
through a single piece of content yet
the b2b marketers in this room would
rather spend a million dollars to build
out a booth
at a convention
or by print ads
or more importantly as all the b2b
people that just raised their hands they
know really deep down their company is a
sales organization not a marketing
organization yet
we are sitting in a time right now where
linkedin
is the close second to tick-tock when it
comes to getting more organic reach for
your post than you deserve
based on the way the algorithm and
supply and demand of content and
attention is playing out
all this world is built on is how many
people's attention is on it
how many people are consuming it and how
many ads
are coming into it three things
how many people are producing content
every day
how many people are over in that world
consuming content and only one other
variable how much money and ads are
coming into it today
if you spend no money on ads
the places where there's the most
attention
and not as enough content to fill it
thus rendering your ability to reach a
lot more people
is tick tock and linkedin one is very b
to c
and one is very b to b
this is what i do daily as a matter of
fact here's a curveball for anybody here
who's very into this world
because of the ios 14.5 update and
trackability
that apple updated that really hurt
facebook many of the dtc and trackable
app advertisers on facebook have walked
away
ironically on the flip side still many
35 year older and older are not there 14
times a day but are still there multiple
or at least one time a week consuming
content
my organization and the organizations
i'm on the board of or an investor of
have gone from not even talking about
facebook as an organic place on your fan
page or running ads for 24 to 36 months
because of the explosion of instagram
linkedin and tick tock to spending the
last six to 12 weeks being obsessed on
how good of a deal facebook has become
again day trading attention
day trading attention means some of the
things of the past may be strong again
as a matter of fact my overall thesis is
not even digital i would be thrilled to
buy more television ads more newspaper
ads and more radio ads if they just
slash the prices by 90
my friends
everything that's going on in the world
everything
that is going on in the world
is based on communication
i was born in the former soviet union
i immigrated to the u.s when i was three
years old
because i had those soviet roots and
because i liked history i did a lot of
homework
as a kid
on history last 50 60 years and there
was something when i was in third or
fourth grade that really caught my
attention which was
what would happen when a country would
have a coup
a coup d'etat
not your normal fourth grade homework
but it always fascinated me
and i never knew why and i always
thought it was this very weird thing
that i was curious about and i read
about a lot of countries overthrowing
their governments
but it wasn't because i was so
fascinated about that part
the thing that kept me interested all
those years in my youth finally made
sense to me in my 30s which was i was
always fascinated why the army
would go to the newspaper station and
the television station at the same time
that they would go to the king or
dictator's palace to overthrow that
person
somehow
as a child i was intuitive that
communication
was the punchline of all of this
i don't have to explain to anybody in
this room we have absolutely been all
very educated
in the last 10 years as the world has
shifted from america to india to russia
and everywhere in between the world has
absolutely recognized
the argument i was trying to make in
2005.
in 2005 678 when i would go to
conferences like this and we would go to
dinner
my argument with the people from the
outside of a small group that believed
in social media was very simple which
was everybody in that table was
underestimating the power of the
platform
i was ridiculed laughed at it was silly
people did not believe that twitter and
facebook could sell anything
only 15 years later everybody
is
always in a debate on how much these
platforms should be regulated how awful
are they or not we went in 15 years from
a place where we did not think that
facebook and twitter could sell a bar of
soap to a place that we think they're so
powerful they can undermine
democracy
that happened in 15 years
what's about to happen with the consumer
blockchain is going to be incredibly
similar
today as i sit here
so many of you
have not even begun your journey
of actually educating yourself
on what a blockchain is
you have opinions
you have
opinions based on one or two or three
headlines you saw
or one conversation with one friend that
has a strong opinion by the way pro or
con you have opinions
but the reality is we do not put in the
work however
why this is important is very simple it
will change the way every single human
being interacts now what's ironic about
it is it is much more web one than it is
web 2.
the reason it's more web one
for the og's in this room
especially even a generation even older
than me
i
heard about the internet in high school
but i had no idea how to even get on it
no different
than people hearing about the blockchain
and nfts but they don't know how to get
a wallet and buy one
i kids
sit down and wait to hear what i'm about
to say
in 1994
i used to pay three dollars a minute to
aol to be on the internet
and if my mom picked up the phone
i was knocked off the internet
think about that
think about that
right now is the biggest opportunity for
wealth distribution
for company growth and decline it's
starting right in our face
consumers
will always pick things that eliminate
friction
in 1996 i told everybody
when i was just entering my father's
liquor store business in new jersey that
i was going to take my dad on the
internet and i was gonna sell wine on
the internet
every wealthy successful business person
that was in their 20s 30s and 40s that
used to come to the store that i would
talk to
said to me
why would anybody buy wine on the
internet you can just come to the store
and get it
they would end with asking me
who
who would buy wine on the internet
i would look them dead in the face
and reply
everybody
in 2007
people looked me dead in the face and
said
why would anybody use twitter
who cares if somebody's eating a pizza
or walking their dog
i would look them dead in the face and
say
everybody cares
humans are very bad at understanding
humans
today
i have dinners all year long and people
say to me nfts are so stupid bill gates
one of the great technologists of our
time
much like he did with the internet
20 years ago said they're scams and
they're stupid yesterday on stage or two
days ago
people say to me why would somebody want
an nft who cares to own a jpeg with a
monkey on it
and if these are stupid
gary who is going to own
how many people are going to own an nft
and for the last year i've looked them
all dead in the face and said everybody
[Applause]
but
let me tell you let me tell you why
because that's more interesting than a
pontification
like the lovely gentleman who just put
up his phone and showed me a v friend
yes people will collect
nfts for collectibility for the art that
is a part of our world
just to remind everybody
when art went to canvases
instead of being on buildings
this is history the only class that i
was good at you can go read it on google
when art
had a big
innovation technology called the canvas
was invented
everybody in the art world said art on a
canvas is not real art it must be on a
building
so art is a part of our society and
collectibles are a part of our society
and that's absolutely true but let me
tell you why i have conviction
that all of you will own an nft
all the nfts are
are better technology for things that
you already want to do
many people here
if i said 15 years ago on this stage
if i was as passionate about nfts
back then about
qr codes
i would say every one of you is going to
use a qr code
many of us would struggle with that 10
years ago because they were not a great
utility it existed some of us as
marketers put it on stuff four people
used it and we deemed it a failure
what i understood about qr codes back
then was it was technology
it wasn't a debate it was technology
today everybody in here uses a qr code a
because
if you want to eat at a restaurant you
need to use it to get the menu
but b
it's your airline ticket you're not
getting anywhere on any airline without
using a qr code
soon that qr code at your airline
will be an nft
it will be better technology
for british airways lufthansa and
everybody else because it will become a
digital asset after you use it today all
of our
airline tickets sit in our apple wallets
and just sitting there from prior
flights
in a decade
they will become micro collectibles
because they will have an artist
attached to it and somebody may offer
you 280 because they follow that artist
for a flight that you took from
bucharest
to mykonos
why is that important why will lufthansa
do that why will british airways do that
because when that person buys
the 280
flight ticket you had because remember
they commissioned an artist to make it
and remember they commissioned that
artist because most corporations have
very big social good corporate
initiatives and they chose this artist
because she's from war-torn ukraine or
she's a dni candidate or this that and
the other thing and then when she makes
it and collectors want all her stuff
including the year where she made all
the airline tickets for a month when
that is sold for 280
british airways gets 10 royalty on that
transaction
so instead of issuing an app or an email
or a qr code for you
that goes into the digital garbage the
day you stop using it
it becomes a digital asset
that becomes a revenue stream
in perpetuity
imagine if this technology existed 75
years ago and there was airline tickets
from andy warhol or or banksy
or whoever you want to choose jackson
pollock knock yourself out
people don't understand that when
technology is built
the mundane the day-to-day every
sporting event ticket
nft every world cup ticket nft concert
nft
go to ebay
and sites like it around the world right
now and see how much
tickets stubs from famous events are
sold every month
the people that issued those ticket
stubs made zero dollars
ebay made the money dhl made the money
the digital infrastructure that the
blockchain creates allows the issuer and
the ip creator to have financial
attachment in perpetuity every club card
you have
to any place the gym restaurant country
club digital asset what people have not
done yet and it's why they make the joke
of oh you bought that nft for twenty
thousand dollars i right clicked and
saved it i have it too hahaha
the reason they make that ludicrous joke
that they think they're so clever about
but in 20 years everyone's going to make
fun of them for making that joke just
like people that said the internet was a
fad is because they don't understand
that the blockchain is not the internet
the blockchain is an invention that
created the ability for the whole world
at any time to know how somebody
owns something digitally and accept it
it is a ledger the same way that you do
you know many people in this place right
now own a home
own a home yeah let's race dance clone's
a home or an apartment
do you know how many of the people that
just raised their hands have no idea how
to prove it
just don't know how a title actually
works that it's a paper or digital
ledger that's centralized and
controllable by others
this is profound technology oh and let
me remind you one other thing how many
people here
have children either their own children
grandchildren or nieces and nephews that
are of the age of
five to fourteen raise your hands
let me just ask this room that has that
have you ever heard of roblox
have you ever heard of minecraft have
you ever heard of madden and fifa and
all this
just to remind everybody
every single child on earth under the
age of 18
is being trained
every day
to believe
and understand
nfts
all of
them all of that
you know my favorite part is
how many people in this room made fun of
their mom and dad for holding on to
their hotmail email
or
dial up
or not getting a smartphone
or not getting an instagram account
for every one of you that's [ __ ] on
nfts in this room in your head prior to
this talk i've got good news for you
you've become your parents
[Music]
now this is very important because i
feel like the last eight minutes have
been very compelling and may have
started the process of people becoming
curious and maybe doing something i need
you to hear something very very very
profound
99
of the nft projects that are in the
world today
will go to zero
it's very important here
what i just talked about for the last 10
minutes is not the friends is not board
ape is not crypto punks it's about the
technology and consumer behavior
as a matter of fact many of the large
corporations here are part of the one
percent because they'll be able to
actually provide utility on the back of
the collectibility we have just lived
through the collectible era with a hint
of utility
we are going to the era of utility with
a hint of collectibility
so before thank you but before
you go and run out and buy something
tonight
you must
you must do 20
30
40
hours
of homework
what and let me tell you how i did it
just two years ago even though i watched
it in 2017 with crypto kitties i bought
ethereum in 15 i was watching but i
wasn't in because the timing wasn't
ready
but two years ago when i got very deeply
like uh oh the hairs on my neck it's
time it's time
i sat on my floor it was covered i put
my youtube on my tv and the first thing
i typed in is what is an nft enter
and i watched
hours
of videos i'm not a good reader some of
you are so you'll be even more efficient
and i had to listen and watch
and over and over and over and over and
over and over and then when i fell in
love with crypto punks which was kind of
not the first ethereum project but the
one that established the way that the
world is working today and i always
believe history
always defeats execution
because execution must be sustained
forever
and so i was very much pot committed to
investing i did 20 hours of why crypto
punks were going to be worthwhile
and then i did 20 hours of searching why
are crypto punks at fad enter why are
crypto punks a scam enter why
i
chose to look at both sides
the majority of this room both into it
or against it
have chosen to only look at one side
this is an important time of opportunity
because let me give you an example how
many people here sell product on the
internet to customers raise your hands
can you put the lights on i want to get
a sense
raise it high please i want to see if i
want to go down this path
i'll go through it quickly here is why
another example why nfts will matter to
so many of you
if you sell product on the internet
using digital assets
to enhance the buyer experience is an
incredible opportunity instead of
selling to somebody one off
as you can imagine whether you're
selling toothpaste or clothes or digital
content getting somebody to sign up for
a subscription with recurring revenue is
a much better business model than hoping
they come back
when you offer your product
if the person buys a subscription they
get a free nft
of value you have now
induced and produced so much more value
as digital assets become valuable and
the cost of them to make is so low that
is profoundly valuable
to the person issuing them not only that
you will now know
who owns it
you will know the customer they will
have it
you can then again web 2.5
use the internet
with the blockchain web 2 web 3
and create web 2.5 experiences where the
individual might have
ordered a one-year subscription to your
business but six months in
you may have a zoom event where all the
people that are subscribers have access
to a one-day digital conference that you
put on and you will know who that is
because they have to
connect their wallet to prove they own
the asset to consume it what will that
do there will be people
who want
to get access to the content who have
not subscribed to you who will buy the
nft off of people
who bought the subscription
you as an organization will make a
royalty on that transaction
that person will consume
the content
will become aware of your brand
potentially sell after the one day the
asset because now the conference is over
you become the central bank and economy
of your organization
if you have no idea what the [ __ ] i said
watch the repeat of what i just said on
google
suck at 90 of things
but for the last 25 years
i was very blessed that my parents had
sex at the right second to give me dna
that makes me uncomfortably intuitive
to what you're going to do
what is very clear to me that you're
going to do is there's not a person in
this room who's not going to interact
with the consumer blockchain at scale
many of us
hear the history of aol google yahoo
microsoft facebook twitter
and we missed it we missed the
opportunity to invest in the stock we
missed the opportunity some of the
executives in here missed the
opportunity to go work at the company
they were scared it was too new
we missed it
i am telling you from the bottom of my
heart everyone
that
the next biggest thing
since the internet itself and social
media itself
is now upon us it is called the consumer
blockchain
there's a ton of confusion one of the
reasons there's a confusion as i said
earlier
there's so much greed
so much greed because there's so much
money attached to it web one and web two
all the money was behind the scenes the
vcs and the startups but the consumers
us we didn't we didn't get to
participate we just used the products
unfortunately and i see this as an
entrepreneur and a capitalist
unfortunately there's so much money
being thrown around that we're seeing
the worst behavior in people trying to
steal and scam
and then even not bad intent people i'm
sure this is not going to confuse
anybody people do dumb [ __ ] for money
and so people are guessing and hoping
and borrowing and just and unfortunately
the market got very hot
for a year
skyrocketed prices so people that were
guessing were winning and when people
that are guessing are winning i'm always
scared
i'm incredibly happy standing here today
based on the last six to 12 weeks of the
correction of the market
it's going to weed out a lot of people
that are going to go on to the next
thing that they think is a quick buck
but the builders
the technologists
the people that understand what the
consumer's actually going to be doing
for the next 20 years this is their
favorite time i want to remind everybody
especially the ogs that lived it to
remember and then for the kids that
didn't live it i want to remind you
when the internet started to get
momentum in 1997 1998 1999 many of those
companies went public
some of those companies
went public in 1998.99 and were worth 80
billion this is back in 1999 that's like
80 trillion today 80 billion
50 billion they didn't have any revenue
the world subconsciously this is very
important sentence the world
subconsciously knew something big was
happening thus
pushing so much money into it
but the thing that was happening wasn't
mature yet
and so what everybody expected me
included i was a kid
somebody asked me yesterday they they're
doing a pretty deep research on me and
she asked me what have you gotten wrong
because she's trying to she wants to
actually get me she wants to razz me
she's like i can't find it and i said i
got lucky everything i got wrong was
before i made content i got a lot of
things wrong in my 20s i didn't
understand timing let me explain how it
played out in 2017 i saw an ethereum
project called cryptokitties
who's familiar with cryptokitties
very nice i saw it
but because i learned the lessons of
timing
in the 90s i looked at it and i said
nobody's doing this yet
it's a very very very small very nerdy
group and i love the nerds they're
always right
but what they're wrong about is timing
too
i mentioned the metaverse earlier the
metaverse makes a lot of sense it's less
friction for the consumer
we're just not there yet the
technology's not there yet the
consumer's not ready
but there'll be a time
the mistake i would have made back in
the 90s is i would be giving this speech
in 2017 and i would have been wrong i
would have been too early
the reason i give this speech in the
middle of 2022 is now we're close
now we're close
millions are involved
hundreds of millions are aware
big corporations
really creative people are all testing
and tasting starting their process this
next five years those internet stocks
that were worth billions 99 of them in
march of 2000 went to zero
history always repeats itself my friends
99 of them went to zero
however
if you did your 20 30 40 50 hours of
homework back then
you might have done what i did
which is you might have really believed
in this one ceo out of seattle left
named jeff bezos who had a company named
amazon and he would have known that
people actually were buying a little bit
from amazon and you would have loved
that the stock during the crash went
from a hundred dollars to four dollars
in the next year
the nft market
will clean itself out
in the one to two percent are the next
amazons ebays and paypals
what i what i desperately want for
everybody here because i want to get an
email from you in 13 years saying thank
you and then they said you know is it
bucharest in 2022 at first i thought you
were full of [ __ ] but then i did the
homework
now i made a million dollars thank you
gary you're welcome sandro
what i want for this room what i came
here to do
was to give
context
clarity
on actual consumer behavior timing
[Music]
with the hope to inspire you to not
listen to me
to not listen to the mainstream media
that always has an agenda to not let the
world advance because it hurts their
business model
to not listen to your one internet
friend
whether they're pro or con but for you
to have the curiosity
and the understanding that
you've lived long enough now to know it
hasn't mattered in the past when you
didn't want the technology you
eventually had to figure it out and it's
always better to figure it out early
to go home and do the work it's a
perfect time it's the summer
a lot of you are gonna go on vacation
a lot of you are gonna do half day
friday
a lot of you are working remote and
actually have a little more time to do
an hour of research
this is the time to get educated on web
3
and start executing web 2.5 web 2.5 for
me the way i define it is when you use
equally and aggressively the current
state of the internet social discord
and the blockchain which i would argue
is the far majority of what's happening
now we are not in web 3 yet we are not
in decentralized servers at sales yet we
don't have a tick tock and facebook
social network yet that's built on the
blockchain that's owned by nobody and we
all use
you know
i actually am going to close with this
i'm going to tell you why i'm so excited
about the blockchain the blockchain is
decentralized nobody controls it
over the last five years
us human beings have gotten very good at
something
let me tell you what that is
we in the last decade have become
remarkable
at blaming everyone and everything
besides our own selves
[Music]
i listen to people
talk about facebook and instagram and
tick tock and china and mark zuckerberg
and this and that
in short order
there will be a leading social network
that is decentralized
rendering nobody in control of the
algorithm
that will be the day that everybody
realizes the algorithm didn't [ __ ] you
up you [ __ ] yourself up
i believe if we are fortunate the
blockchain
will become the foremost technology
to allow us to start the process of a
more brighter decade
one that we all realize that
accountability accountability
is the foundation of happiness
it may not be fun to face the mirror and
understand your shortcomings it's not
fun for me i have plenty
but i promise you
you want some anxiety to come off your
chest you want to smile a little more
than worry
it starts with accountability and i
believe as we head into this
decentralized world accountability will
gain momentum and that will be good for
society
bucharest i love you thank you for
having me
[Music]